hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seven days to die
and I have my good friend here or giant
douche Wade also known as Lord minion
777 alone as Rick you look like me but
you are you think you love me but I do
you look so handsome there me how do I
go into third person because I know that
you are me f55 oh it is this is like
Minecraft it's trying to get monka blah
oh wow don't hit me okay we need to
cooperate in this apocalypse
yeah we need to not kill each other
that's the ideal okay so anyway as you
guys could tell I was having a horrible
time with this game I wasn't able to do
anything and I'm a giant noob and a
loser in a video so wait is here to help
me we're surely not gonna die now that
Wade is here rightly yeah I will say I
died I died a lot my let's play of this
however all unite played just the two of
us yeah and we went nine days in a row
without dying once oh good
30 minute days yeah I stopped had no
food at all now teach me how to play
all right well are you punching that
zombie man what that's all he ever do to
you yeah give me I did find out that you
need to collect as many supplies as
possible especially during the early
part of the first day uh-huh just the
ground even though this is like solid
ground and not dirt under a tree to get
the tree to break oh oh that would have
made it so much easier I'm an idiot and
now I'll get a little bit of stone too
which is nice what does stone do it's
just stronger than wood at fortifying
like a house or a structure what is
would do goes up your blood uh-huh don't
I don't want you like three years to say
that to you Shane hahaha well Rick I put
wood up lori's whoa what this is a drug
minecraft at all want to say that to you
we have no excuse for saying anything
bad in inappropriate because this is a
family show family show kids are
watching my pills were a fan
Oh than yours is do you ever curse on
your channel I think I've slipped up a
couple times but generally no I try not
to yeah I've actually tried to be better
about it I mean a lot of people like
love me to drop f-bombs all the time but
I mean cursing doesn't make something
funnier that's not really comedy that's
cheap comedy nothing I'm good about MIDI
anyways generally if you're cursing it's
your genuine reaction yeah for your
genuine reaction yeah yeah yeah if I'm
scared yeah I'll drop enough bombs but
if I'm just playing foreplay I usually
try to keep it clean because here let's
put something in that bag for you what
would you put the bomb there you go oh
it's a dildo oh this is not a little the
devil just I have this like empty lake
there's my screen bloody what I don't
see anything wrong with you
I don't see anything wrong I don't it's
like an empty lake of nothingness that
you ran across um I don't know what's
going on in your end but I don't know if
it goes fine over here I will tell you
we're probably like one of the worst
starting spot I know I started here
before and actually things were
terrifying me like seriously there are
jump scares all over the place yeah I
don't like this place none of these
buildings are good for holding off in
that I found something in my eyeball ah
now that's tiny there's a zombie
apocalypse mark no here's a hole hey
what do you take care of my eyeball
first oh it hurts it stings my eye and
my retina it hard I've worked with those
things before thank you
eyes and retinas cuz that's your job now
it is kinda tighten it here what present
for you in here the gun then I can shoot
you with I mean not shoot you
whoa-ah not shoot you not shoot you at
all but I'm trusting you behind my back
with a loaded firearm oh just wait until
we play trouble it tears down my friend
I don't know what that is but it sounds
terrifying you've never played trouble
in terrorist town Oh have you seen my
videos of it no you don't watch my
videos I didn't say I don't watch your
videos I see those video no it was
probably best that whatever I play it
with you I don't know what I'm getting
like yeah actually that's probably true
because then I can exploit you by the
way guys we will be recording prop hunt
and TTD after this with bob bob is
getting dinner tomorrow
cuz they know what order we record
things in shut up oh no we're just
trying to keep him informed they liked
me before brick I think we'll try to
hold off in here though this building
kind of sucks I got a bed I picked up a
bed you want a bed that's good is there
an extra one glass John no it's just one
for the both of us why would you offer
me a bed if there's not one well I got
you for us to share because I love you
oh good we get to cuddle hey I got
feathers I don't wanna cuddle I kind of
want to come okay what do we do I hear
an angry puppy what do we do what are
you punching where are you I'm in I'm in
a building where what's that where where
uh you wait in front of you wait where
well I'm writing for oh there you are
okay you are right in front of me you
douche hey man Mad Dog leader
well that cheerleader ever do to you he
was gonna be a valuable number she's
wearing blue and white oh wait what are
we that I poor ankles chair no one knows
well actually everyone's gonna know
because your webcams over there but I
mean I don't know you should know you're
you live here live where Cincinnati we
have a football team Oh what's a rock I
thought it was a bag Wow you freaked out
over wrote this yeah way to go you're
not gonna survive the zombie apocalypse
if you're scared of rocks I'm just gonna
say that right now I need to find I'm
gonna break more trees you keep
searching for supplies okay will do if I
find another bed I'll let you know I've
got one we're good you caught with damn
it
mmm how do you we're gonna look for one
flaming I was you didn't know that I had
a feeling they don't even do that much
other than set a spawn huh I got a
feelin hey where's Michael Jackson
Anna's gonna be a good evening
turnin because I don't think copyrighted
songs ever
anyway breaking out into song all the
time I than having to stop myself what
the oh it's you
yeah sorry oh my
I was grabbing your wood hard sorry you
want it back now you can keep my way oh
thank you everybody is it anyway haha
what's wrong I had one Rick yeah I said
the same thing to Lori last night Rick
if I had one no the other thing
shut up trying to stuff Rick you're
always turning things around on me mask
you so much
turning things around Oh what does that
me mask you so Franco what the hell does
that mean hey you think you know but you
don't
anyway where'd you go you disappeared
again I'm all just collect supplies and
stuff and you should collect supply you
mean are we gonna hide in one of those
building s teams boring I don't want to
do that do you not want here you know
what I know where we're going what
follow me I don't see you there's a mat
left corner oh you're on that yeah well
I'm I don't I seem dumb yes come on
don't be like that
alright serious mode everyone's gonna
get mad at me if I don't take this
seriously
alright we are trying to survive just
I'm having fun go just please let me
have fun Oh Chris boom you gave him the
mattress I don't think that zombie wants
to sleep with you I mean no offense to
your devilish good looks but uh every
time I think I mean a nice undead guy
okay I'm sorry as you know that and so
oft it does doesn't it well I mean it
doesn't happen that's why you need to
take your chances when they come o my
lord my my map is not so it does not
like you being in this game you know I
don't know what's going on with yours
but I'm doing just fine
like seriously when you update it cuz
you updated a four point one maybe
there's some problems because you didn't
delete the other one I did though oh
well maybe it just doesn't like you it
does I don't know who never not like you
but I'm just saying it buries another
handgun and I will tell you if you take
that handgun and put it with your other
one put it one in the middle and one on
top of it in your inventory it will
repair your gun and do more damage no
way luck in the crafting table yep
they're dirty and make sure you keep
your gun and ammo on the bottom bar
luckily reload I learn I learned that
much what I did learn is that there's
zombies you got to get food and you need
Wawa which we're not gonna get in this
area are we what's that I see a tower
probably not go to the tower
what tower this is tower oh that's it
now there's two towers it's like the
Lord of the Rings what what would you
say
infected woman just died oh that poor
lady I know she's here know what got her
antibiotics quick enough that's really
sad looks like totally survivable we're
gonna try to hold off in this building
tonight yeah yeah we're gonna do it
we're gonna do a skip
whoo-hoo you know you quiz don't let's
get on Ringo Christopher Walken here I'm
telling you skip don't wants to hear the
Christopher Walken why my that for me
airline food hey airline food hey
shuttle I I'm trying to what the heck
where'd you get water you think give it
to me I'm gonna drink this gasoline
lady's standing here just like with
their arms out like she's being searched
oh she disappeared oh I don't see what
you're talking about
I'm the car the light I gotta spoofing I
got gas the lead where'd you get water
there white car is backing up what I
don't know what's going on with your
game but I'm doing just one either but
it's freaky everyone check out Wade's
channel for whatever the hell he's
seeing because he's weird over
apparently very suave Wow my god
Lika I got there's a fast one why are
they fast they're not supposed to be
fast in the day for some reason
sometimes they're fast inside I guess
because it's Darden ego boost like it's
nighttime oh that's kind of cool
actually but they like vampires they get
lethargic in the daylight something like
that I guess if you reload early do you
lose the ammo yes fudge
nurse joy oh I didn't go in the building
I stayed outside the bill sorry for
punching you earlier
I mean Oh fat Ace Ventura hey that's
actually a really good observation he
does have that shirt Oh what about what
is this I don't know what is what this
thing what is what looks like a landmine
but I guess it isn't what is what over
here what thing I'm standing on oh oh I
I don't know it was like some kind of
mine or something I think it's um a seat
for guys to like that sort of thing I
make torches I'm gonna make some torches
torches done I got rags did Knight isn't
that what you need for have rags and
would you break down the wood into
plywood plywood in the sticks Oh God
how do you break down only a little bit
of wood right click and you know it did
all of it you're lying to me if you pick
it up and just like right-click it down
you lie to me you lied to me would I lie
yes yes that's what really why do you
think that's what you would do all right
but I didn't oh wow you did make a torch
so do they get slow if you're nearby the
if they're in the kind of the light area
oh you're putting them down that's so
cool ah okay now that I'm actually with
someone that knows what he's doing this
actually is pretty interesting game
still not a hundred percent on if it's
worth the cost right now but this game
has potential like no joke I know I've
been digging around a lot but I mean on
my channel i played with molly latin
zombie and JP yeah and I will say it's
more fun with more people
I could I could see that I could
definitely see that okay alright we have
to block off like all these other
staircases with wood now with like wood
wood yeah whatever we've got I got wood
yeah baby
I got wood or get weighty weighty baby
weighty weighty baby where do you come
back you can't blame it all on me bit
176 all too many sticks
hahahaha waiting way to fail Oh
ah what the hell you didn't warn me I
can't drive this shooter what you're
going to die you're gonna deliver louder
oh are you okay yeah you need me to kiss
your wounds with this knife Oh God ah
nurse where are they coming from I'm out
of ammo
so uh go unlock oh my god it's dazzle
what is that sound
nothing good it's not like so sugar
sugar sugar sugar sugar you guys you get
Jim you see this is Wow oh my god where
did it come from this is what we're
gonna die aren't we were gonna die this
is not looking good we owe my God if we
die what happens do we have to start a
new game cuz we'll start it a night
um well technically no but it'd probably
be a good idea wouldn't it would
probably be a good idea
our eternal quest to survive the night
all right let's move up to like the top
floor some people quit scaring us from
out of nowhere I leave until house how
many torches do you have uh six more
okay all right I'm gonna block off both
be stairways here with only would I know
can they break down would ya how fastly
pretty fast so I would make it no no I
didn't ask how fast I asked how fast
bleah answer me correctly pretty fast
Lisa thanks Rick thanks for the approval
southern hands answer cuz you're welcome
PUD what is that I don't know
oh don't leave me here swing the floor
there is a hole in the floor oh uh wait
wait he come back I will
you can play real
where I jumped in the hole cuz it's time
for the episode to end alright so anyway
um did better a thing did everybody yeah
I was uh
don't expect me to take this too
seriously but I'm gonna try to actually
do this um we're gonna try this again
we're gonna start a new world but for
now we're all at at times though thanks
Wade for trying to teach me we're doing
pretty good until you left up I fell
through the hole in the door yeah okay
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the image taste of war
videos that I've done
check out wage channel see what was
going on over his King and as always we
will see you in the next video
man
figure skater back in
god damn it put on your kids
but in the game just over
we're playing doctor talking robot
slippers
Oh drink you bastard
yeah